[Musik]
sechs jahre und einen tag nach dem
deutschen überfall auf polen
unterzeichnet japan am 2 september 1945
die kapitulationsurkunde
der zweite weltkrieg ist beendet
wie viele menschen in diesem krieg
gestorben sind wird niemand je genau
wissen ebenso wenig den namen des ersten
oder dem des letzten opfers
[Musik]
doch es sind menschen die in diesem
krieg gelitten und gekämpft haben
ohne sie wären panzer nicht gerollt
flugzeuge nicht geflogen
und schiffe nicht gefahren
im krieg geht es um menschen
mit
oder ohne uniform
[Musik]
menschen in städten
dörfern
welt an
verbündete fremde
[Musik]
verfeindeten nachbarn
hunderte millionen menschen
die sechs jahre und einen tag lang
die hölle auf erde durchlebten
[Musik]
rückblick
1919 wird der versailler friedensvertrag
unterzeichnet damit endet formal der
erste weltkrieg die deutschen müssen
hohe reparationen zahlen und die
kriegsschuld anerkennen sie fühlen sich
verraten und gedemütigt
1943 formulieren die alliierten auf der
konferenz von casablanca ihr offizielles
kriegsziel die bedingungslose
kapitulation des deutschen reiches keine
friedenskonferenz mit nazi deutschland
schließt sie aus
in berlin ist die stimmung schlecht
hitler hat gerade die kapitulation der
in stalingrad kämpfenden sechster armee
abgelehnt
am 13 januar 1943 einen tag vor der
konferenz von casablanca er geht ein
geheimer führe erlass über den
umfassenden einsatz von männern und
frauen für aufgaben der reichs
verteidigung
hitler verordnet damit den totalen krieg
am 18 februar 1943 die deutschen truppen
haben inzwischen den stalingrad
kapituliert joseph goebbels im berliner
sportpalast seine berüchtigte propaganda
rede vor 3000 ausgesuchten zuhörern
seine berühmte rede über den totalen
krieg zum ersten mal gab er zu dass das
vaterland verwundbar dass der sieg nicht
mehr absolut sicher war
fanatisch stimmt der
reichspropagandaminister die menge auf
noch härtere einsätze ein
die inszenierung ist auch eine
demonstration nach außen
die ganze welt soll die bedingungslose
bereitschaft des deutschen volkes zum
totalen kriegseinsatz mitkriegen
der bus mit trockenbau mitchell sprach
über viel mehr als die industrielle
produktion
ich muss er sprach über die deutsche
volksgemeinschaft und über die größte
schicksalsstunde der nationalen
geschichte meist
als goebbels den totalen krieg verkündet
gibt es im berliner sportpalast kein
halten mehr
noch 20 minuten nachdem gewiss das
gebäude verlassen hat jubeln die
handverlesenen claqueure
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kurz darauf verschafft
generalfeldmarschall von mannstein der
deutschen in der dritten schlacht bei
farc auf meinen letzten erfolg an der
ostfront
manstein drei coaches betrifft manstein
eroberte die stadt charkow zurück
dadurch stabilisierte er den
südabschnitt der front wie bereits im
norden gab es jetzt auch einen südlichen
bogen den sogenannten kursker bogen
erst vier monate später am 5 juli
greifen die deutschen den sowjetischen
front bogen um die stadt kurz kam sie
nennen die operation unternehmens-it
adele doch die rote armee hat ihre
stellungen am kursker bogen inzwischen
ausgebaut
humphrey handelt etwa 300.000
sowjetische zivilisten waren für den bau
von verteidigungsanlagen mobilisiert
worden sie hoben insgesamt 9000
kilometer in schützengräben aus und
bauten unterirdische bunker pro
quadratkilometer vergruben sie tausende
minen
[Applaus]
die sowjets legen eine halbe millionen
panzer abwärme und rund 440.000
antipersonenminen
bevor die luftwaffe mit dem angriff auf
kurs beginnt
es ist die letzte deutsche großstadt mit
union
auf seiten der roten armee stehen 1,9
millionen soldaten und 5000 panzer die
wehrmacht rückt mit knapp 800 1000
soldaten und 2500 panzern an
zehntausende geschütze feuern
die bomben fielen die artillerie feierte
überall waren panzer man hörte die
befehle kaum ich schrie befehle nach
rechts und links
[Musik]
aber niemand verstand sie will zeigt mit
unseren beinen nach rechts oder links um
die richtung vorzugeben
die schlacht um kurs beginnt am 5 juni
hitler hatte folgenden operation befehl
verfasst jeder für jedermann muss von
der entscheidenden bedeutung dieses
angriffs durchdrungen sein der sieg von
kurs muss für die welt wie ein fanal
wird
das war eine harte zeit sehr hart
[Musik]
die deutschen messerschmidt flogen 15
oder sogar nur sieben meter über dem
boden
ich spürte regelrecht um die deutschen
atmeten sie schossen und schossen
wir warfen uns auf den boden und hörten
die kugeln vorbeizischen
manche von uns schrien andere konnten
nicht mehr schreien sie waren schon tot
[Musik]
die schlacht von kursk ist die größte
schlacht des zweiten weltkriegs und die
größte panzerschlacht der geschichte
überhaupt
[Musik]
nach elf tagen des kampfes treten die
deutschen den rückzug an mit der
niederlage in kursk befindet sich die
wehrmacht an der ostfront auf dem
rückzug
[Musik]
einige menschen kamen bei explosionen in
den schützengräben um
andere gingen in den nahkampf um den
feind zu vertreiben viele wurden
verwundet und verstümmelt
aber gott sei dank konnten wir in der
schlacht von kursk unsere aufgabe
erfüllen
[Musik]
kursk war in meinen augen absolut kein
wendepunkt des krieges es war ein
wendepunkt der sommeroffensive 1943
kursk war das ende der deutschen
initiative an der ostfront
[Applaus]
schätzungen zufolge liegen die verluste
auf deutscher seite bei rund 50.000 mann
nach sowjetischer seite bei knapp
180.000 mann
[Musik]
die rote armee verliert circa 1.600
panzer die wehrmacht rund 350
aber das sind nur zahlen der sowjetische
soldaten erinnert sich
es war eine kurze schlacht sie begann am
fünften juli 1943 am fünften august gab
es ein feuerwerk
[Musik]
ein paar tage zuvor auf der anderen
seite der erde in burma dem heutigen
lama
eine von den japanern eingesetzte
marionettenregierung erklärt die
unabhängigkeit burmas von britischer
herrschaft und den alliierten den krieg
ein britisch malaria dem späteren
malaysia hatte die japanische armee das
land 1942 besetzt die japaner waren von
thailand aus durch den dschungel
vorgerückt
wir hatten angst
es gab schlangen und kleine aber giftig
furchteinflößend sehr giftig
eines tages sah ich einen skorpion vor
meinem haus ich dachte oh ein skorpion
und schnappte ihn mir aber dann stach er
mich mit seinem stachel ich hätte ihn
nicht fangen sollen einen halben tag
lang war man am taub und ich musste so
gehen
[Musik]
die japaner patton rangun bombardiert
ein überraschungsangriff der ein paar
tausend zivilisten das leben kostete
[Musik]
ein chinesischer soldat beobachtete
damals wie die letzten riten vor den
japanern flohen
leichen lagen am straßenrand mit
goldschmuck behängt aber niemand nahm
ihn jemand mag einen soldaten schmuck
gegen eine schüssel reis zu tauschen der
soldat sagte gold ist nutzlos
über die britischen frauen sagte hughes
der
weiße haut war schlamm verschmiert
der rückzug der briten war qualvoll
hunderte kilometer durch größtenteils
schwieriges gelände oft bei furchtbaren
wetter auf straßen voller flüchtlinge
große teile der ausrüstung mussten
zurückbleiben
ein general berichtete später über die
männer dass sie wie vogelscheuchen
aussahen aber gleichzeitig auch die
soldaten
die britischen truppen die in boma von
chinesischen soldaten unterstützt werden
ziehen sich nach indien zurück eine
britische verbindungsoffizier zufolge
herrschte im führungsstab eine
atmosphäre der düsternis die kaum zu
beschreiben war
[Musik]
im juli 1942 ordnete das japanische
hauptquartier die planung eines
dreigeteilten vorstoßes nach indien an
doch der britische oberbefehlshaber in
indien archibald label startet im
oktober mit dem arakan feldzug eine
gegenoffensive
der arag an feldzug scheiterte aus
mehreren gründen die alliierten waren
offensichtlich nicht gut auf den
dschungel krieg vorbereitet
und außerdem waren die japaner noch
voller energie sie konnten sich den
briten nicht nur entgegen stellen
sondern auch gegen angriffe starten
[Musik]
mitte mai 1943 erklären die briten den
arakan feldzug für verloren
ihre verluste liegen bei etwa 5000 mann
kranke nicht mitgerechnet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die japaner die immer noch die kontrolle
haben beklagen knapp 2000
die britischen und indischen soldaten
benötigten dringend eine bessere
ausbildung und vor allem brauchten sie
mehr esprit kampfmoral optimismus und
zuversicht
die sind die ersten bruder des soldaten
oder die britischen truppen für den
handel und dschungel ausbilden soll um
die japaner auf ihrem spezialgebiet zu
besiegen
umwelt achtet auf jedes detail kreis
kleinigkeiten kosten krieg leben die
ausrüstung eines mannes dem dschungel
lebt und kämpft ist enorm wichtig
der britische major general port wingate
gründet eine spezialeinheit mit dem
namen die in diez die meisten soldaten
kommen aus britischen und indischen
truppen befindet sollen hinter den
japanischen linien operieren und aus der
luft versorgt werden
zum ersten mal in die nachrichten
sehen sie genau hin selbst ihre mutter
wurden sie nicht erkennen
wer auf einen einsatz vorbereiten und
ziemlich lässig aus aber diana
plädierte dafür dass einzelne gruppen
weit hinter den japanischen linien für
unruhe sorgen soll
[Musik]
die japaner mussten truppen von der
front abziehen um mitzuhalten umgeht
nannte das die hand in den eingeweiden
des feindes haben
[Musik]
die erste expedition startet anfang
februar 1943
ende märz wird der rückzug angeordnet
weil die versorgung aus der luft nicht
mehr gewährleistet ist
die 3000 mann starke truppe hat es dahin
schon knapp 800 mann verloren 600 der
zurückgekehrten soldaten sind
kriegsinvaliden
zwei wochen später kommt will gates bei
einem flugzeugabsturz ums leben
[Musik]
januar 1944
chang kai shek der vorsitzende der
chinesischen national regierung schickt
einige seiner besten divisionen nach
burma zur unterstützung der briten im
kampf gegen die japaner
und das obwohl er warnt
es ist zu erwarten dass japan in kürze
eine großoffensive gegen china starten
wird
[Musik]
die chinesischen divisionen bleiben in
burma aber dafür zahlt china einen hohen
preis
[Musik]
die operation zur deutsch operation
nummer eins ist eine groß angelegte
aktion der japaner während des zweiten
weltkriegs sie beginnt am 19 april 1944
sie wollen die amerikanischen
luftwaffenstützpunkte in china
neutralisieren von denen aus bombay
japanische städte angreifen
[Musik]
außerdem soll ein nachschub korridor
zwischen nord china und vietnam geöffnet
werden
400.000 soldaten kämpfen auf japanischer
seite und 900.000 auf chinesischer
die einzige transportmöglichkeit die
eisenbahn der bahnhof arbeit mit 20.000
und die waffeln
die chinesische verteidigung bricht in
nur zwei monaten zusammen 34 chinesische
divisionen lösen sich praktisch in luft
auf
die chinesische armee erleidet enorme
verluste ein hochrangiger offizier
beobachtet
jedes mal sobald der feind seinen fuß
irgendwo aufsetzt entsteht eine narbe
werden häuser zerstört
[Musik]
als ich nach hause zurückkehrte hing das
bild meines bruders bereits über unserem
haus alltag
er ist in china gestorben er wurde dort
getötet
der landkorridor nach südostasien bleibt
eine utopie
die amerikanischen flieger sind schon
nicht mehr auf chinesische stützpunkte
angewiesen einzige offizier der
operation die kommunistische partei
chinas
ihr hauptquartier liegt im abgelegenen
yanar an wo sie energie für den kampf
nach dem krieg sammelt
[Musik]
anfang april 1944 die 31 die vision der
japaner belagert den britischen
stützpunkt balkon auf indischem gebiet
nahe der grenze zu burma die indo
britischen soldaten sind darauf gedrillt
nicht aufzugeben der befehl letzter mann
letzte patrone captain jack lang aus
glas koffer dabei da mein befehl lautet
bis zum letzten mann zu kämpfen werde
ich der letzte mann sein
nach fünf tagen belagerung erhält die
garnison verstärkung durch ein bataillon
auf britischer seite kämpfen zu großen
teilen soldaten aus indien ein
historiker schreibt später das nirgends
im zweiten weltkrieg mit solcher
wildheit gekämpft wurde wie im kino
die briten halten die stellung und die
japaner wenden sich der stadt im palazzo
durch deren einnahme wollen sie den
briten die möglichkeit nehmen burma
zurückzuerobern
aber auch hier kämpfen die alliierten
mit großer entschlossenheit
erfreulich war schwer ihn wieder
unteroffizier führte den rest der truppe
an aber man sah ja nicht da war nur
alles grün der waschechte junge leben
[Musik]
plötzlich ertönte ein schuss ich konnte
nicht weiter ich wusste ja nicht wie
viele japaner oder wer auch immer da
waren da war nur diese eine chance
[Applaus]
sie erschossen unseren unteroffizier und
ich trug ihn zurück ich rechnete damit
dabei auch getötet zu werden
anders als die britischen einheiten sind
die japaner von jeglichem nachschub
abgeschnitten
dazu kämpfen sie in unwegsamem gelände
gegen einen gut organisierten feind
und den monsun
[Musik]
der dichte wald bringt alle möglichen
abnehmer miteinander das ist nur langsam
vorangeht wenn man die schwierigkeiten
wir wurden per fallschirm versorgt
integrationen wurden von der air force
abgeworfen so was hatten die japaner
nicht sie jagten unseren paketen
hinterher
[Musik]
die japaner standen auf gold 10 viele
von ihnen hatten goldzähne
stieß man auf tote japaner musste man
sie durchsuchen wir mussten nachschauen
welche kennzeichnung sie trugen
eine job ein typ aus dem westend
regiment sammelte ihre zähne er hatte
einen kleinen beutel voller gold zehner
dollar fest ich habe mir das nicht
ausgedacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass die japaner nicht gewohnt sind
aufzubieten lässt sich an ihrer mimik
ablesen
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich genau so sehr wurde es
uns eingebläut sieh zu dass du stirbst
erlebe niemals die schande der
gefangenschaft egal was passiert du
darfst nicht gefangen genommen werden
ich bin jetzt 90 und erinnere mich immer
noch daran sie waren so gründlich darin
uns dieses denken zu vermitteln ein
gefangener durfte nicht lebend nach
hause kommen und dann
[Musik]
am ende des krieges versuchte ich zu
fliehen um nicht in gefangenschaft zu
geraten
trotzdem schnappten sie mich führten
mich ziemlich weit weg und sagten da
rein
[Musik]
es war eine drei meter tiefe grube eine
zelle es gab keine leiter und wenn man
einmal drin war kann man nicht mehr
heraus drei meter waren einfach zu hoch
die usa sind groß und krieg ist falsch
aber ich hatte keine andere wahl
was soll man tun wenn man arm ist
[Musik]
die doppel schlacht bei im pool und
klima ist ähnlich wie stalingrad ein
wendepunkt im zweiten weltkrieg
die leute das ende des japanischen boma
feldzugs 1 auch wenn die japaner noch
versuchen burma zu halten
[Musik]
um die truppen zu versorgen bauen sie
eine eisenbahnlinie
sie brauchten eine landverbindung an den
enden gab es bereits schienen kein allzu
großes problem also
in japan gelang etwas was die briten nie
geschafft hatten die bürger sie bauten
eine eisenbahnlinie von west thailand
bis nach ost burma
zwischen 400 kilometer gleise gebaut in
unglaublich kurzer zeit
bangkok
die so genannte einzelstück
sowie 25.000 an youtube kriegsgefangene
an davon starben etwa 12.000
kriegsgefangene
hunderttausende von zivilen sklaven das
weiß kaum jemand hauptsächlich familien
in die arme malaysia und so weiter
[Musik]
krankheiten und den japanern hilflos
ausgeliefert und die japaner keine gnade
ich glaube es starben etwa 80.000
asiatische arbeitskräfte
sie wurden wie sklaven getrieben
geschlagen wenn sie stehen blieben
einige wohnung zu tode geprügelt
schwerstarbeit unter tropischer sonne
männer sterben wie die fliegen man sagt
für jede bahn schwelle ist ein mann
gestorben
ein mann starb allein das war immer
jemand an seiner seite man redete mit
ihm man tat alles was man konnte selbst
wenn man keine hoffnung mehr für ihn
hatte sprach man zu ihm um ihn zu
trösten
alles wird gut kumpel mach dir keine
sorgen die wahrscheinlich wussten sie
dass gar nichts gut wurde
[Musik]
aber männer sind nicht die einzigen
opfer der berüchtigten eisenbahn des
todes
ein australischer gefangenen erinnert
sich an die nächtliche ankunft eines
zuges junge frauen steigen haus die
japanischen wachen stehen schlange um
die frauen werden trost frauen genannt
auch sie sind gefangene vergewaltigungs
opfer des kriegs sie sind teil eines
ausgeklügelten systems von
zwangsprostitution in japanischen
kriegsflotte
auf 100 japanische soldaten kommt eine
trust frau
mädchen und frauen aus korea taiwan
indonesien und den philippinen
sie werden von den japanischen behörden
quasi fast klafft eine überlebende
berichtet
ich wurde mehrmals fast getötet es gab
männer die betrunken waren und mit
schwertern auf mich los gingen sie
verlangten perversen sex
auch in deutschland gibt es
zwangsprostitution
organisiert von der ss die in zehn kz
lager bordelle betreibt die nazis
nötigen weibliche gefangene zum sex die
darin oft ihre einzige rettung vor dem
tod 10 eine frau aus dem lager bordell
in buchenwald erinnert sich
nicht mal übers wetter wurde geredet
alles war mechanisch sie benutzten uns
und gingen
auch bei massenerschießungen von juden
kam es vor dass die mörder ihrer opfer
vorher vergewaltigte
als die sowjetarmee deutsches gebiet
erreicht waren vergewaltigungen an der
tagesordnung damit der pausen sowie
monorail hunderttausende frauen wurden
vergewaltigt über die sowjetarmee sagte
stalin ihr denkt dass die rote armee aus
helden besteht aber ihr solltet nicht
vergessen dass es gewöhnliche besatzer
sind
ich ging auf den hügel um nach
russischen lastwagen ausschau zu halten
fehlanzeige unten war eine hirten mit
ihren siegen als ich runter kam sagte
sie komm mal her was du schon zu hause
ich sagte nein
es ist der seine schwester ist von einem
lastwagen voller russischer soldaten
vergewaltigt worden der letzte hatte sie
verstümmelt und in die nächste gruppe
geworfen
panacol
[Musik]
der totale krieg hat viele grausame
schauplätze und seiten
sexuelle gewalt ist eine davon eine
andere abgesehen von kugeln und bomben
bis die wohl tödlichste waffe des
krieges sie kostete 20 millionen
menschen das leben
[Musik]
hunger
in indien china und vietnam trägt die
japanische expansion direkt oder
indirekt zum tod von mindestens fünf
millionen menschen bei
[Musik]
indien noch mehr hunger 1000 tote pro
woche tendenz steigend
die ursachen für die hungersnot sind
umstritten
[Musik]
die auswirkungen sind es nicht
in ihrem bemühen die japanische invasion
zu stoppen zerstören die briten
lebensmittellager und tausende von
flussschiffen
getreidehändler spekulieren mit ihrer
ware beides gilt als ursache für die
hungersnot
andere verweisen auch auf die
auswirkungen eines tropischen
wirbelsturms und auf eine missernte im
jahr 1942
fakt ist aber dass britisch indien 15
prozent seiner reis vorräte verloren hat
als burma im frühjahr 1942 an die
japaner fiel
anfang 1943 erlebt bengalen ein teil
britisch indiens eine schwere hungersnot
mit geschätzt drei millionen toten
winston churchill soll damals
hilfslieferung gekürzt haben mit den
worten
es gibt keinen grund warum nicht das
gesamte britische empire genauso unter
der krise leiden sollte wie das
mutterland
die swatch acrobat ein schuldirektor
schreibt
die ganze bevölkerung scheint sich
lautlos auf den tod zu zu bewegen damit
meint er sicherlich nicht das mutterland
oertel sieht großbritannien als
weltmacht und ist ein verfechter des
british empire in churchill sagte indien
ist genauso wenig eine nation wie der
äquator indien als eigene nation hatte
für ihn keine bedeutung er lehnte
indischen nationalismus völlig ab
während einer hungersnot geht es ums
nackte überleben
kinderreiche familien haben es besonders
schwer einige bauern gehen dazu über
ihre töchter für die nacht zu vermieten
[Musik]
ein augenzeuge beschreibt eine andere
verzweifelte situation
ich sah rund 500 notleidende männer und
frauen fastnacht und skeletten
abgemagert acht von ihnen verendeten
direkt vor meinen augen was mich
zutiefst erschütterte
dies thema zum da schreibt im namen
seines dorfes an der spanische
hilfskomitee
es gibt hunderte von kindern entweder
verweist oder verlassen sie brauchen
dringend milch gerste wasser und so
weiter wenn sie überleben sollen
es ist die stunde von fiat marshall
archibald wafer er wird zum vizekönig
von indien ernannt und handelt in dem er
preiskontrollen einführt und der armee
befiehlt hilfslieferungen an die
hungernden zu verteilen
aus london kommt nur wenig unterstützung
das kurzsichtig und gefühllos als er
erfährt wie die lebensmittelknappheit in
den niederlanden mit lufttransporte
behoben wird bei merkel dass es offenbar
einen großen unterschied macht ob es
sich bei der hungernden bevölkerung um
europäer handeln endlich werden
maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der hungersnot
in britisch indien ergriffen die sorge
um die truppen gibt den ausschlag
schließlich werden soldaten für die
rückeroberung burmas zusammengezogen 60
prozent davon kommen aus britisch indien
auch in der region tolkien im norden
vietnams gab es im oktober 1944 eine
schwere hungersnot dass sie von menschen
mit verursacht wurde ist wenig
umstritten
denn tonkin herrschte eine schreckliche
hungersnot gut eine million menschen
starben weil die japaner ihnen die
lebensmittel wegnahmen und sie dann
exportiert
5 prozent der vietnamesischen
bevölkerung starben
in der provinz henan in china verhungern
im zweiten weltkrieg mindestens zwei
millionen menschen dürre frost hagel
heuschrecken naturkatastrophen hatten 75
prozent der ernte vernichtet nicht nur
die bevölkerung musste versorgt werden
sondern auch 300.000 dort stationierte
japanische soldaten
[Musik]
im februar 1942 besucht der
amerikanische journalist guido raith die
provinz von einem arzt erfährt er dass
eine frau in der not sogar versucht
hatte ihr baby zu kochen
[Musik]
als japanische truppen angesichts der
operation kino in die betroffenen
gebiete zurückkehren rächen sich die
bauern und entwaffnen bis zu 50.000
soldaten
viele werten ermordet
auch in europa sterben millionen an den
folgen des hungers in
griechenland herrscht im herbst und
winter 1941 42 die so genannte große
hungersnot in folge der ns
besatzungspolitik
die lage wird verschärft durch eine
mittelmeer blockade großbritanniens
georgia weigert sich anfangs beharrlich
internationale nahrungsmittelhilfen
durchzulassen oliver littleton
britischer kriegsproduktion minister
schickt ein telegramm an die regierung
ich glaube die geschichte wird ein
strenges urteil über unsere politik
fällen
die zahl der todesopfer in griechenland
300.000 im märz 1942 lenken die briten
ein aber das leid in der sowjetunion
stellt all das noch in den schatten
hier sterben während des krieges an den
folgen des hungers bis zu neun millionen
menschen zwischen sechs und sieben
millionen in den gebieten unter
deutscher kontrolle einschließlich der
kriegsgefangenen entfachung anlassen war
teil der ns kriegsstrategie
drei bis vier wochen reichen aus um
einen menschen mental fertig zu machen
danach dauert es noch eine woche bis er
oder sie auch körperlich am ende ist
genau das haben wir an der ostfront
gesehen sie kümmerten sich weder um die
ernährung der leute noch um eine
unterkunft
es gab nicht genug essen für die
menschen vor allem nicht für die kinder
[Musik]
die hungertoten sind das eine
wie viele durch unterernährung bleibende
schäden erleiden oder an krankheiten
sterben die mit dem mangel an nahrung
zusammenhängen das weiß niemand
[Musik]
die landung auf sizilien
dank einer der großen versionssprung in
der geschichte
[Musik]
der landung wie schwierig mächtiges
wombacher auf
weihnachts- werfen sie leuchtraketen auf
die schiffe
sie beleuchteten sie wie eine bühne dann
kamen die storz kampfbomber
das credit kreischten furchterregend als
sie den konvoi angriffen
[Musik]
einige schiffe wurden versenkt mitsamt
den truppen darauf chips
die alliierten waren gelandet und
gewonnen die schlacht auf sizilien
zur gleichen zeit flammte in rom ein
aufstand auf der dusche hatte seinen
glorreichen moment gehabt seine legionen
hatten über 20 jahre lang im mittelpunkt
gestanden
der tag der abrechnung gekommen
ende juli 1943 stimmt der faschistische
grossrat für die absetzung mussolini
den würdigen die abstimmung fiel mit 19
zu 7 stimmen aus er versuchte das gar
nicht an sich ran zu lassen so als
merkte er gar nicht was geschah er ging
nach hause legte sich schlafen und kam
am nächsten morgen ins büro als wäre
nichts geschehen
dort wartete ein krankenwagen mit
getönten scheiben um ihn ins gefängnis
zu bringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hitlers general alfred jodl merkt an
dass die ganze faschistische bewegung
wie eine seifenblase zerplatzen
faschistische symbole fallen menschen
die dreieinhalb jahre gelitten haben
feiern kamera weit würden sie in frieden
leben so dachten sie zumindest wollte
rita die unter der sonne glückliche ort
sein der es einmal war da
italien unterzeichnet am dritten
september 1943 einen waffenstillstand
mit den alliierten
dies führt zum bruch zwischen dem
deutschen reich und italien die
wehrmacht beginnt mit der besetzung des
landes
sagen die flucht das deutsche exporte um
korrekt zu sein und er sieht auch ganz
schön ex aus deutschen volke und jäger
befreien ihn auch der gefangenschaft ein
deutsches flugzeug bringt ihn zu hitlers
hauptquartier
nach dem treffen mit hitler und
mussolini nach italien zurück er
übernimmt die führung eines marionetten
regimes in der kleinstadt hallo am
gardasee nach der landung der
westalliierten im süditalienischen
salerno ordnet hitler einen
schrittweisen rückzug an
die erste verteidigungsstellung ist die
gustav linie auf halbem weg zwischen
neapel und rom
[Musik]
sie haben mich die deutschen kamen in
voller stärke wir eröffneten das feuer
und die schlacht begangen
hejazi kapierten schnell dass wir nicht
genug waffen hatten um sie
zurückzuschlagen
halo wars ist die granaten prasselten
auf uns herunter
ihre stellung war höher als unsere sie
machten uns das leben sehr sehr schwer
einmal waren sie so nah an uns dran dass
ein deutscher offizier bei uns durchlief
und etwas von einer kompanie an oder so
lief
dann wurde er erschossen und live shows
er wusste nicht wo er war er dachte er
wäre bei seinen eigenen leuten so nah
kamen sie heran
von januar bis mai 1944 starten die fest
alliierten fünf offensiven gegen die
gustav linie auf der auch die
benediktinerabtei monte cassino liegt
die sogenannte schlacht um monte cassino
ist eine der längsten schlachten des
zweiten weltkrieges
mit schweren verlusten auf beiden seiten
das französische expeditionskorps unter
general alfons schmitz dem zweiten
polnischen chor den weg am 18 mai nehmen
die soldaten die klosterruine ein und
hessen die polnische flagge
[Musik]
explore the
night and
gentlemen the new german als
repräsentatives element
die alliierten setzen ihren vormarsch
fort und auch in die festgefahrene lage
in der bucht von antibes kommt bewegung
in der operation schinkel waren hier am
22 januar 1944 amerikanische und
britische einheiten gelandet dem rücken
der deutschen verteidigungsstellung in
monte cassino verbrechen single one das
oberflächlich betrachtet war die
operations schenkel eine wirklich gute
idee das ziel war an der küste zu landen
und so die gustav linie zu umgehen die
die deutschen in mittelitalien ausgebaut
hatten
unter dem kommando von major general p
lukas waren die alliierten gleich am
ersten tag fast ohne gegenwehr fünf
kilometer ins landesinnere vorgedrungen
aber anstatt weiter vorzurücken blockes
den brückenkopf abregeln und verliert
zeit das nutzen die deutschen aus- und
kesseln die landung truppen mit sechs
abwehrte visionen ein die homepage er
saß am strand und verschanzte sich ist
das war im grunde genommen richtig
entsprach aber natürlich nicht im plan
zügig ins landesinnere vorzurücken
ende februar wird lukas abgelöst am 11
1944 starten die alliierten operation
bei der am 23
gelingt den eingekesselten truppen der
ausbruch umstand abschnitt in anziehung
die großoffensive richtung rom nimmt
fahrt auf
[Musik]
am 15 mai ordnet generalfeldmarschall
albert kesselring den rückzug zur
torlinie an die nächste vorbereitete
stellung
james thunder die deutschen nutzten
unter albert kesselring einem der
größten deutschen befehlshaber des
krieges das italienische tara und klima
brillant aus
[Musik]
anfang juni erklärt generalfeldmarschall
kesselring rom zur offenen stadt
am vierten juni 1944 marschieren die
alliierten in rom ein
während die deutschen noch durch die
nördlichen außenbezirke abrücken wird
die fünfte us armee von der bevölkerung
begeistert begrüßt
[Musik]
noch vor dem fall roms hat kesselring
beschlossen sich auf die nächste
position zurück zu ziehen die guten
stellung
der angriff der alliierten beginnt ende
august und wird fortgesetzt bis im
dezember gelände und wetter den
vormarsch zum stillstand bringen im
april 1945 wird er wieder aufgenommen
die kämpfe dauern weniger als 1
ss general karl wolf handelt unter
missachtung der order aus berlin mit den
alliierten
am 29 april einen tag vor hitlers
selbstmord und einen tag nachdem
partisanen mussolini und seine geliebte
clara petacci erschossen haben wird die
kapitulationsurkunde unterzeichnet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber zuvor bietet noch der letzte akt
des krieges in westeuropa und an der
ostfront im pazifikkrieg rücken die
alliierten immer näher an die
japanischen hauptinseln heran die welt
steht in flammen und das leid und der zu
zahlende preis steigen ins unermessliche